Discovery Channel's Deadliest Catch
depicts the real-life risks of Alaskan
crab fishing however the show doesn't
quite catch everything let's dock the
sea star Time Bandit and all other boats
to get a closer look at Deadliest Catch
Elliott neeses rehab stay during season
11 of Deadliest Catch
then captain Elliott Neese abruptly
handed over the helm of the saga to
first mate Jeff Hulk and left his ship
leaving viewers wondering why he went
AWOL after rumors swirled in tabloids
about his addiction problems these
himself tweeted in May 2015 that he'd
entered a 60-day program at passages
Malibu for an undisclosed program he
wrote that he'd had issues but after his
stay at passages had a new outlook on
things now needs his restraining order
it seems Elliott Neese is a magnet for
trouble
back in 2012 he got himself slapped the
restraining order according to documents
cited by Entertainment Weekly
it seems he'd been harassing his baby
mama Valerie Gunderson for the better
part of a month maybe more in her
petition Gunderson said she'd feared for
her personal safety in the event that
Elliott snaps so to speak she also
claimed that during one incident in 2010
niece got so angry that he destroyed her
television and then started burning her
clothes in the fireplace it seems that
for Gunderson snagging niece's heart was
a pretty deadly catch in and of itself
freddie maughtai bathroom brawler
apparently fella t freddie malvit i has
some mixed martial arts ambitions
according to a criminal complaint
obtained by TMZ Bogota he got involved
in a fight against a husband-and-wife
team in the bathroom of the Grand
Aleutian hotel back in December 2011
mavet eye claims he was defending
himself when he put the husband in a
headlock and shoved the guy's wife
police arrested him despite a story he
was later fired from his ship for an
unrelated incident but maybe he should
look into bringing his untapped fighting
prowess to the Octagon each of his
fights could be called deadliest match
done tonight you'd watch it Jake Harris
drunk driver Jake Harris son of the late
captain Phil Harris seems to have made a
smooth transition from crab fisherman to
reality star back in 2010 Jake was
arrested for a hit and run driving under
the influence and driving with a
suspended license after crashing his BMW
in Seattle according to People magazine
supposedly Jake had a tough time dealing
with his father's death but while that
may explain his action
certainly didn't justify them plus it's
not the best way to honor his father's
legacy neither was his other
indiscretion
Jake Harris's drug struggles in November
2010 TMZ reported that captain Derrick
ray of the Cornelia Marie had called
police to the boat because he suspected
Jake Harris was abusing drugs while at
sea police discovered Parra familiar but
it wasn't enough to charge Jake with any
crime a few years later Jake was
noticeably absent from Deadliest Catch
as 2013 promos according to his brother
Josh via Huffington Post Jake was lost
in drugs obviously still reeling from
his father's death Jake's got to take
care of his own stuff right now deal
with his demons said Josh fortunately as
of August 2015
Jake was clean and captaining his
father's old boat Joshua tell Warner
Hank Robert
despite the crimes committed by the
other Deadliest catchers Joshua tell
Warner might be the biggest criminal of
them all according to CBS News Warner
was one for a series of bank robberies
that took place in Oregon from 2007 to
2009 so what did Warner do to lay low
he appeared on television Oregon law
enforcement officials recognized Warner
during a 2010 episode of Deadliest Catch
and immediately issued a warrant for his
arrest
Warner pled guilty to reduce his prison
sentence from 30 years to nine and a
half years sidenote for any aspiring
bank robbers the only time you should
appear on TV is on cops
drug trafficking producers even the
people behind the scenes on Deadliest
Catch are magnets for trouble production
manager Matthew Schneider was charged in
April 2010 for selling and using cocaine
according to the Associated Press
Snyder's illicit activities were
discovered after he allegedly sold about
$300 worth of the stuff to an undercover
officer and used some of it in front of
the officer as well oops he also
revealed that some other show employers
were involved in a drug trafficking
affair which resulted in the arrests of
18 people Hillstrand brothers abandoned
ship the best thing to happen to a
breakout character on a hit show was
scoring a spinoff unless they're the
Hillstrand brothers in 2010 discovery
offered Johnathan and Andy their own
show to be called Pihl stranded
discovery even started filming footage
for it however when the time came to
record voiceovers and polish everything
up the brothers were nowhere to be found
according to E online
this didn't sit well discovery you
slapped them with a three million dollar
lawsuit
the hillstrands retaliated by leaving
Deadliest Catch all together taking fan
favorite captain sig Hansen with them
they all eventually made up but the
hillstrands trouble didn't end there
fireworks Follies the Hillstrand
brothers may need to hand over some
money to crewmember David beaver
Zielinski according to seattle pi in
2013
the hillstrands wanted to celebrate his
Seattle Seahawks victory by shooting off
some fireworks because yeah shooting off
fireworks on a boat is a good idea under
captain's orders so let's keel it off a
mortar like a foolishly obedient
deckhand the firework which was made by
the hillstrands exploded while he held
it shattering the bones in his hand and
forearm beaver filed the suit in 2015
seeking an undisclosed amount looks like
choppy waters ahead for the hillstrands
after all Alaska dislikes the show while
viewers still love Deadliest Catch
Alaska had its fill of the show
according to Alaska dispatch news to
summarize the complex issue the boats
featured on the show are making things
difficult for the rest of the northern
crabbing fleet to earn a living it seems
that the Discovery Channel's funding of
fishing expeditions in a whole er part
has affected the cruise not
participating in the show and something
it difficult for them to keep up in some
cases let's cruise end up earning
minimum wage and crabbing us far too
dangerous for such minuscule pay on the
other hand it does afford Discovery
Channel the opportunity to create a show
about former fishermen now living on
Skid Row
behind the scenes fakery like most
reality shows Deadliest Catch is guilty
of dressing up the events that happen in
real life
in their case producers made it appear
as though one of the ships was in danger
of being sunk by huge waves during a
storm which is an honest hazard of crab
fishing
however the episode in which this is
dramatized was filmed in September 2008
while the waves themselves were filmed a
month later according to The Hollywood
Reporter unsurprisingly the Discovery
Channel denies any trickery caught
red-handed or perhaps
red-clawed thanks for watching subscribe
to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw and
leave us a comment to tell us what
surprised you the most about the
deadliest catch crew